thank you david thank you shane patricia
for presenting
before so uh i'm not sure if you can see
my slides
do you see it correctly yes
yeah so uh this is this is really
i should say the first time that we are
presenting our uh
our plans and well hopefully uh they
sound
ambitious but but possible and really we
want to hear some feedback and do our
homework and
and see what we are doing well and what
we
we should adjust but i should start
maybe from uh what we heard already in
in this in this workshop is the main
theme
is that uh people since ancient times
have been
fascinated by this perspective of
talking to animals
and we can find examples in old myths
and legends and
fiction stories such as edison
wonderland or the adventures of dr
dolito
i should say that myself as a little kid
i uh
maybe wasn't really aware of the idea of
language and what is language or the
system of communication so
i probably like many other kids i
wondered
why can't we really talk to animals why
don't they speak in our language
and in the scientific community this uh
question whether
other species have anything similar to
human language
and whether we can interpret it has been
around for a while and we've seen
from from from the talks today uh a few
examples of uh how broad
the spectrum of species that have been
considered
and so we are obviously not the first to
attempt understanding the language of
animals
and multiple such efforts have been done
in past decades
and many research groups have analyzed
on human species communication and even
tried to talk back to animals
and i think this research has produced a
lot of
more understanding about these species
but i should say
i don't want to sound arrogant but none
of them succeeded at least in this
far-fetched goal
to really understand what animals are
talking about and talk back to them
and why would it be different this time
and i think the answer to this is
threefold it's
the right choice of this thesis the
right approach
and obviously the right combination of
expertise
and the team so in terms of this species
i hope the shane in his
previous talk convinced you that if you
were to bet on
one animal which might have something
that is even remotely close to human
language
it would be the sperm whale so these are
mammals with very large and very
developed brains
with very rich social life with family
with culture
with intricately complex communication
system
which shares some of the hallmarks of
human languages
now in terms of the approach i believe
that we now have this
rare opportunity for the first time the
we possess the technological
capabilities that
allow us to analyze on human
communications
in a qualitative better way and our goal
is to use
industrial level approaches for data
collection
analysis and data-driven methods based
on machine learning
to try to accomplish this task
so let me take a step back and look in
retrospective
on the evolution of human language
analysis by computers a feel that is
called natural language processing or
nlp
and we will have tomorrow a wonderful
talk by jonathan
who will uh talk about some of uh the
the uh
detailed uh details and the recent
advances in this field
but we can see that early approach is
heavily relied
on upper your assumptions about the
language for example in the form of
handcrafted rules or grammatical
structures
and this limited the scope of our
application of nlp
to languages that we know and required a
lot of human guided processing and
annotation
and it obviously precluded the
applications and settings where
the language is new or unknown which
appears also to be our case we don't
understand the language of wales yet
so what happened in the field more
recently is a shift from handcrafted
rules
to statistical and machine learning
models that can
extract the structure and rules from the
data itself from examples of text and
in particular in the past decade the
emergence of deep learning techniques
has caught caused a paradigm shift and
breakthrough in performance of nlp
methods
uh deep learning as you know is a
collective name for artificial
usually neural network-based systems
that are trained
uh using back propagation techniques on
massive collections
of data and while these matters existed
for
probably at least 50 years it was the
conference of three trends
that really made them so remarkably
successful
this is algorithmic and architectural
development
increasing computing power in particular
the use of graphics hardware of gpus
and probably most importantly the
availability of
large data sets that could be exploited
for training
and deep learning was especially
successful in fields such as computer
vision
speech recognition and also nlp and
created literally out of almost nothing
multi-billion dollar industries
and whenever you drive your tesla car or
use the siri application on your iphone
it's deep learning systems operating
under the hood
i mentioned siri and they see my iphone
responding to it so that's
probably a good example that it's
working
in uh nlp applications it is typical to
see
architectures uh called encoder decora
and an encoder is a neural network that
operates on a sentence that is
represented as a sequence of tokens or
roughly you can think of them as words
and produces a
multi-dimensional uh vector
representation for each word typically
these are a few hundreds of dimensions
that are called word embeddings
and the meanings are used as a kind of
intermediate representation or you can
think of it if you wish an imaginary
language that
tries to preserve some structure of the
original input
on the other hand a decoder is another
neural network that is applied to the
embeddings and produces the desired
outputs from them
and the decoder is task specific for
example if the task is translate
english into uh italian the decoder will
convert
the input embeddings uh into
corresponding sequence of italian words
and a different decoder will be used for
let's say english to russian translation
and if we have a completely different
task like to detect spam in your mailbox
the decoder will output a classification
whether the input sentence from
an email message is likely to be a spam
so uh the main drawback of this
architecture is that
it is supervised and this means that it
relies on
known pairs of inputs and outputs and
for example in the case of translation
from
english into italian we need to provide
examples of sentences
in english and their counterparts in
italian
a kind of rosetta stone that was famous
famously used by
champagne to decipher egyptian
hieroglyphs
and where would such rosetta stones uh
come from
you know that in case of the the
egyptian language
it was actually the same uh the same
text written in three different
languages
some of which were known one of them i
think was greek
so that's why it was possible to
translate
the egyptian language and uh it is
interesting that
nlp is probably one of the few cases
where bureaucracy
has helped progress research rather than
hindering it and one of these examples
is
that in the european parliament all
important documents are translated into
the official languages of europe so
there is a large collection of texts
what is called a parallel corpus with
one-to-one correspondence between
multiple languages and this corpus of
documents was collected
collected and curated probably about 15
years ago
and was used to train machine
translation algorithms
and yet the reliance on this label data
that somebody has collected these
corresponding uh sentences or words
that required human efforts to annotate
it is a big bottleneck sometimes it's
extremely costly
to produce and the breakthrough in nlp
came from
the realization that the embeddings can
be pre-trained
in a self-supervised way where there is
no human labeling but the data itself
is used to guide the training
so given a sentence you can mask out
some words and
make the neural network predict the
missing words from their context
a kind of fill in the blanks exercise
and
learning to do these apparently simple
tasks that
for example my six years old son
routinely does it at school
it actually requires a deeper
understanding of the structure of the
language
and neural networks appear to be capable
of doing it provided
a large corpus of examples it also
appears that
pre-training a neural network in such a
way produces embeddings that
are somehow almost universal they can be
used for many downstream tasks
so for example a simple classifier
applied to the world embeddings
can detect if the input comes from the
spam email or the sentiment of the text
is happy said or exciting or
any other task that you want to do with
your language
still machine translation relied on
known translations or corresponding
words across languages
and that is to say until recently in
2018 a group from facebook ai research
showed that
it is possible to do completely
unsupervised translation
and for this purpose the embedding four
words in the language can be considered
as
some kind of high dimensional point
cloud that is shown here
just in two dimensions but imagine the
same thing in 200 dimensions
and if we train embeddings of two
languages say english and italian as
shown here
completely independently by this idea of
filling
the blanks we get two such point clouds
and it appears that they have similar
structure and can be geometrically
aligned basically by
this multi-dimensional rotation maybe a
little bit of non-rigid
alignment as well in this high
dimensional space producing
essentially automatic correspondence
between words or
what we call a translation and it seems
to be
working in languages that are as
dissimilar as english and chinese
so how large a data set is needed
to train modern language models let me
give you an idea of the order of
magnitude
so a model from 2018 called birth use
the data set collected from the english
wikipedia
and it contained roughly 2.5 billion
words
uh the generative pre-trained
transformer or gpk2 model developed by
openai uh used a bigger data set of
about 10 billion
words or tokens and in your version of
the model gpt3 that that
is now creating a lot of hype in the
machine learning community
released just a few months ago it used
really a colossal data set of half a
trillion words
and as a side note i should say that
this gpt3 model
is probably the largest and more complex
neural network that has ever been
trained
it has 175 billion parameters and the
estimate of the cost of training such a
model i
read some numbers that are uh totally
mind-blowing
uh uh north of five million dollars so
think of
the amount of energy that that is spent
in in trading such such neural network
so let me go back to strongwell because
i think we took a detour
in uh natural language processing that
that hopefully tomorrow we'll hear
many more details about it so project
seti
is an initiative as david mentioned that
tries to harness
their progress in deep learning in order
to gain new understanding of
the communication of sperm whales and
before attempting to apply
modern machine learning technology to
whale by acoustic data as we know it is
very data hungry we need to ask a
crucial question are we anywhere close
to these
uh gigantic data set scales
so in order to estimate how much data
well communication produces
we can do a simple back of the envelope
calculation
and uh as uh shane mentioned and he's
talking the area of
around 20 square kilometers off the
shore of dominica that
he and his team have been studying for
the past 15 years
between 50 and 400 whales are observed
it obviously depends on the season
and other situations these whales
vocalize nearly continuously with again
estimated
about 70 percent of their vocalizations
used for echolocation
and the remaining 25 of the clicks
are used for communication what we call
the codeclicks
and in the caribbean across different
locations
the code structures fry but uh the
typical coder
in the caribbean has five clicks and
lasts approximately four seconds
which produces a rate of information of
about
roughly slightly more than one symbol
per second
and overall this uh gets us to the range
between uh 400 million to four billion
clicks per year
so this is obviously a rough estimate
probably somewhere somewhat optimistic
upper bound
but it gives us the ballpark of the
amount of data that we can potentially
collect
and use for a machine learning pipeline
and you can see that it's comparable in
size to what is used in human language
analysis
just to give you a comparison uh the
dominica spread well project probably
one of the largest bioacoustic data sets
that shane and his team have been
collecting in the past
15 years and that we've been using so
far
has less than 100 000 uh annotated
clicks
so you can do the calculation yourself
it's orders of taking too
less so we're talking about a
qualitatively larger data set
that we believe to be really a game
changer in the field
so let me say a few words about what
kind of data we are trying to collect
first of all just a massive collection
of vocalizations that will allow us to
train
unsupervised world embedding kind of
models so same way
as uh in human nlp research
uh basically massive amounts of text
collected from anywhere like english
wikipedia
without really any innovation issues uh
just to predict uh the structure of the
language
and as participating so far
our another approach was to consider
codas as the basic communication units
and in this way we have prototypical
patterns of sequences of clicks
with uh certain intra click intervals or
icis which are roughly equivalent to
human words or at least this is
a convenient analogy and this might be
an overly simplified assumption since
codas are produced by
clustering and we see a great deal of
variability between colors of the same
type
and we don't know whether this is due to
variations in neutrons similar to the
different
manner to different people would
pronounce the same word
same way as uh when i speak and somebody
else thinks we
have slightly different uh pronunciation
or if there is a fundamental variation
that conveys meaning
which we are not taking into account so
one thing for sure is
to try to revisit from the from the
foundations
the entire concept of colors and basic
units of
sperm whale speech
furthermore the assumption of clicks
being broadband pulses and
only intervals between them carrying
information might be too simplistic and
shane mentioned it and patricia
mentioned it as well
we see evidence that clicks differ in
their spectral content and amplitude
and there is some evidence but we still
lack a clear understanding whether
uh which of these variations result from
recording artifacts
which come from the sound or production
mechanisms such as
maybe reverberations inside the head of
the whale that produces
these different interpol's intervals and
which of them are intentional and uh
whether these
spectral cues are used by the whales and
their communication
so same way as we can recognize they
check each other by the spectral
characteristics of our voices
we see that whales might be using these
cues but
i think it's not certain yet i'm not
even sure that whales
you have the anatomical capability
to intentionally control some of these
parameters of their voice
so i think there are many questions that
still need to be answered at
all levels of fields of expertise
secondly we are interested in collecting
whale conversations where we have
a dialogue between two whales or maybe
conversations
with more whales and this will allow
training more complex complex machine
learning models
that are not just trying to predict the
next intra click interval
or coda but also the response of while
one whale to another and if we're able
to reach certain acres here in this task
we will attempt to play back predicted
responses
and think of it as a kind of interactive
whale chatbot
and several attempts that that we are
aware of in the literature
of people trying to play back playback
sounds
to the whales but to the best of my
knowledge it has never been really an
interactive uh machine learning system
that tries also to
respond in real time to what uh what it
hears from from the web
and finally the overall structure of the
data set we are trying to collect is
uh a network of interactions uh between
wales
and because of my job at twitter i like
this social network metaphor
we are trying to build the whale twitter
and uh the nodes of the social graph are
whales for which we know the identities
demographic data their location and some
behavioral metadata over time
and the agents are instances of
communication or interactions between
different whales or maybe groups of
whales so we might even talk about
more complex structures than just edges
so when i said in the beginning that the
success of deep running can be
attributed uh primarily to the
availability of
large scale data sets uh some people
even call this the
the data the new oil i think it was
andrew and
that that produced this this analogy
uh in the sense that that modern machine
learning techniques are very data hungry
and require massive amounts of
currently created data that sometimes is
very expensive to produce so
once you have the data that uh it solves
at least half of the problem
so the data set that we are trying to
build here both in size
and the level of details and
complexities completely unprinted
unprecedented in marine biology
and collecting this data set is really a
gigantic effort
that requires a synergy of different
expertise and this brings me to the
third pillar of project city which is
key to its future success
and this is the team and
uh i think in this regard we have the
most amazing team ever possible and i'm
really truly honored to be part of it
so david uh who is also the uh
one of the organizers of this workshop
hence the entire collaboration
and uh as david and jaffe mentioned we
met
during the wonderful year at the
broadcave institute for advanced study
at harvard
where we all were fellows
and uh shafi organized
a series of machine learning seminars
where we discussed different papers and
invited
different speakers and david showed us
the whale
sounds and also organized an evening
where
we all uh watched the star trek movie i
don't know if you're
fans of of this series about there is uh
one movie about where there are whales
or there are not sperm whales i think
humpback whales
that travel in in the future
but bottom line basically we got i got
interested in this
in this project and we teamed up with
shane
has been working on sperm whales and is
one of
the biggest authorities in this domain
and uh
we wrote this proof of concept paper
with
either being a berman and and uh robot
which really tried to use uh
machine learning techniques of the the
modern types such as
deep neural networks uh to try some of
the the problems
that were before solved uh using uh
older techniques and uh the the
advantage of using machine learning
techniques
uh that they allow to build models from
the data rather than
handcrafting them so uh i mentioned
shane who
heads the the biology work we also have
as our advisor
roger payne a pioneer of way of research
that
discovered the whale songs in the 1970s
on the engineering and sensor design
part which is extremely important
with a very an underwater acoustics
expert
and a professor at the university of
haifa and
on the all the operations uh the the ceo
of the collaboration is dan chernov has
experience in building
marine stations in different places in
the world
so robotics plays an important part as
well and
here we have rob wood a pioneer of soft
robots for real life exploration and
daniela rose
who is also part of the machine learning
team who has developed some of the first
uh underwater autonomous robots and
on the side of data analysis and machine
learning we have antonio toralba jacob
andreas
and patricia sharma whom we met in the
previous talk
from mit and shafik goldwasser and
myself
on the linguistic side we have kevin
ryan from harvard
and we also have giovanni petty from
from easy who is
a complex network scientist and assa
raskin and britselvitel from her
speeches
who uh have worked before on uh other
non-human species communication and last
but not least
we also have the creative media and
communication side
with uh then dilani from uh
national geographic uh christian michael
lawrence
movie director and uh james nestor
journalist
and as david mentioned uh in june said
it was announced as
one of the audacious projects funded by
private donors under the aegis of
ted and it is really their generosity
that
will make our dream a reality so this is
something we're
truly indebted for for the trust and
support
so let me say a few words about how we
are going to collect
this data set and here we are primarily
counting on three classes of
assets uh or types of sensors that will
be
deployed in the watches of dominica and
uh first we'll be using static sensor
arrays to collect massive amounts of
background
by acoustic data and these are big
devices you can see
uh in this picture that was from uh
provided by rui
they are similar in their design to some
of the military underwater equipment
that is used to detect submarines on
large areas and distances and each such
array
is attached to a buoy that will consist
of multiple hydrophones
in rigid configuration that we call oil
recording units
that will be positioned at different
depths with about 200 to
300 meter increments and the use of
multiple hydrophones and multiple buoys
we
plan having four at least will allow to
detect the location of whales and track
them over time
and this will help to solve the
so-called cocktail party problem
the need to unmix multiple sources of
sound in recording which
arises when using just a few microphones
like it
was done in the past and typically done
marine uh by acoustic uh recordings
the boys will also record metadata such
as the ocean and weather conditions and
water temperature
that is unnecessary for for example for
calibrating the speed of sound
necessary for doing the translation
and uh despite these tracking
capabilities we are not sure yet if the
boys will provide enough accuracy to
uniquely identify the
whales and you can think of a possible
situation
when a whale disappears from the field
of view or maybe stop stopping for a
long while and then reappears
so we'll probably not be able to say for
sure if uh it is the same whale
re-appearing or a new one though we are
also considering using spectral
information
in order to try to do speaker
recognition and
probably what also helps is that usually
their
sound is directed so we can try to
estimate the
direction of arrival but there are still
many open questions here
the second type of assets we'll be using
for data collection there are tags
that are attached to whales and you can
see here an example of such tags
of the same type chain and his team were
using in the
dominican from whale project to do some
of the recordings
and the tags are attached to the whale
body on
the head and records not only the whale
by acoustics but also signals from
inertial and pressure sensors
allowing to reconstruct the motion the
diving pattern and
other behavioral patterns and maybe in
some of them you can also do
a video recording uh the main limitation
of current tags is battery life and
adhesion
so this is a big engineering challenge
to make sure that they can
be firmly and gently attached to the
whale for a long period that will be
enough to collect
interesting recordings and here i should
stress that
our overall philosophy is to act in a
minimally invasive way that doesn't harm
or disturb the
the animals so we plan using advanced
active suction mechanisms
for example to attach these tags and uh
there are again many challenges here as
well how to place
these tanks so far uh it's just a boat
with a very long stick
uh maybe we can do something that is a
little bit more sophisticated using
robotic systems the use of the tags
one of the things that will allow is to
uniquely identify the whales
in conversations and associate also the
metadata such as behavioral patterns
with background recordings that are
produced of the static
sensor arrays and by reconciling these
different sources of information
we'll be able uh to have a full picture
about both individual whales
and the population and finally as a
backup option and there's a way to
ensure that we don't have any blind
spots
in our data collection we also consider
developing swimming robots that could be
deployed in
some interesting locations where the
crowds of whales and collect
data complementing these static arrays
and attacks
and here again there is a wide spectrum
of solutions from
simple drifters such what is shown here
so
more sophisticated self-propelled robots
with automatic navigation
so this is still again something where
we are defining and overall
our goal is to uh to do a large scale
longitudinal study of sperm whale
populations over
several years and we are striving to
collect
uh massive amounts of bio acoustic data
suitable for
machine learning approaches and we
believe that this data will help us
understand the behavioral interactions
and acoustic communications of these
animals
very interesting side project that shane
also briefly mentioned is studying the
development
of the language in car calves or baby
whales
and same way as human babies gradually
develop language and
i think we'll have a fascinating talk on
this tomorrow
uh starting from simple bubbling to
first words uh
career in sentences shane uh has seen
evidence of a similar process taking
place
in baby whales and understanding how
this happens could
shed light on the structure of the way
language
and the language development development
and cognitive
capabilities so our
ultimate goal is finding evidence of
language-like structures and this is
where the role of ml will be crucial
we'll use ml
in a variety of tasks well starting from
the very simple signal processing tasks
such as detecting clicks and separating
location clicks from communication
clicks
as protrusion mentioned reconciling
different recordings
and identifying different worlds and
conversations
producing self-supervised embeddings by
trying to predict the next boot
transfers whether it's individual
clicks or entire colors or sequences of
colors
and again as i mentioned we'll revisit
our current assumptions or on what
constitutes
the basic information of um units uh in
world communication
and uh in particular whether the clicks
themselves carry any content
and we'll look at conversations we'll
try to predict replies building a whale
chatbot
and we'll try finally to find evidence
of higher level structure
such as recursion which is believed to
be unique to human language
and association behavioral information
to buy acoustic data
will look for evidence of displacement
or the capability
of language to communicate about things
that are not immediately present
in time and in space which is also a
feature that
is believed to never been observed in
other animals
so to conclude i think seti is
really once in a lifetime opportunity
and
i would say without exaggeration
probably the craziest
moonshot i have participated in and i
hope that i was able to convince you
that we are not just streaming
but uh we will really make it happen
so thank you very much